I come from a family that loved theater.
And I love the mistakes, I love the messiness,
I love the seams.
But I've always been afraid, if I ever did theater
and I made a mistake or I messed up,
what would happen?
Have you ever had an experience in the theater like that?
And if so, what did you do,
and what would your advice... ?
Well, I don't even know where to start.
Right?
(audience laughs)
I mean, essentially, 25 years
in London and here,
I mean, I've been set fire to in mid-air on wires.
(Drew laughs)
In Andrew Lloyd-Webber's "The Wizard of Oz,"
that we did at the London Palladium,
I had like, a finger flash fire
that would launch at the Scarecrow, as you do.
(audience laughs)
Down on the deck.
And set fire to him.
He'd set off something.
But my costume was completely black, inky feathers.
And the finger flash didn't go off.
"Oh boy," indeed.
(audience laughs)
And I moved my hand back onto the broomstick,
and my whole dress went on fire.
What did you do?
I went.
(audience laughs)
Mid-air.
And how funny is this?
That very day,
my beloved friend Clay Aiken
was in the audience watching me,
and was like.
(Hannah screams)
(audience laughs)
Hey, hold on, broomstick.
Witch.
Don't get me started.
You are in the new "Hocus Pocus."
(audience cheers)
I'm freaking out!
This movie is so meaningful and important to so many people.
Sam Richardson was here the other day.
Sam Richardson who is in "Ted Lasso" as well!
That's right!
Oh my God!
And so I grilled him about it.
Oh my gosh, it's immense.
What is it like?
I would have paid them for the privilege.
But don't tell them that.
(audience laughs)
So I arrived for my costume fitting in Rhode Island,
and the second AD was like,
"The ladies would love to meet you."
And I was like, "The...?"
The ladies.
"Them? The witchy ladies?"
And he was like,
"Yeah, they're just finishing up on a scene,
"but if you'd like to come to set..."
And I was like,
"Yes, please."
And got driven there,
and they came off set,
and there were Dame Bette, Kathy,
and SJP sitting there.
(audience cheers)
Having their lunch.
In a little box like we all do on set.
In their costumes.
It was just like...
And I said, "I just wanted to quickly come
"and say hello."
And Bette,
Bette.
(audience laughs)
Was just like, "Come, come and sit."
And I was like, "No, no, no, no,
"you're having your time, I get it.
"I know it's down time."
"No, no, no, come and sit with us."
And they were just
so delicious.
And
Bette was just like, "Well played.
"Well played for this year."
And I thought,
(audience gasps)
"I can't even believe you know I exist.
"I can't cope with it."
It was just insane.
(audience cheers)
It is absolutely, right?
She is something.
And my daughter is obsessed with the film.
Especially Kathy Najimy with-
(Hannah makes indistinct sounds)
I mean, it's "Hocus Pocus,"
I've seen it probably a hundred times.
I'm so excited.
I'm so excited for this gift.
We all need this like "Ted Lasso,"
we're all gonna be like.
"Mmm, yum, yum, yum."
Yes, yes!
Okay, there's one other character
that I have to talk to you about.
Is it true...
(Hannah cackles)
That you are
the nun in "Game of Thrones"
I am.
Who literally says the famous phrase?
Shame!
(audience cheers)
Yes!
I am!
(Hannah laughs)
So don't screw up.
Otherwise I'll get you with my bell.
I've got my bell.
Did you save it?
That's when you know that you're dead.
(audience laughs)
On the show.
'Cause they're like, "Here you are, here is your hero prop."
There we go.
I had breakfast with Miss Headey this morning.
No way!
Yeah, oh, we're in love with each other.
Wait a minute!
We love each other!
I don't know what I want more to picture,
"Hocus Pocus 2" and you and SJP and Kathy Najimy
and the divine Miss M,
or that you and Lena Headey were literally like...
I had scrambled eggs this morning.
(audience cheers)
We are great pals.
(upbeat music)